uh
yeah
i feel like a lot of energy right now
and welcome to the podcast this is hans
kim coming to you live from austin texas
we got gareth fisk here he showed up
late he's not playing [ __ ] you
why are you yelling who are you yelling
at me
you have no one to blame by yourself we
said the game started at 1 30.
it's almost 2 30.
five six i mean i don't whoa dude sit
down
chill out i gotta go smoke a cigarette
you're gonna die out there
shut up
okay so we're live
so you are right here it's rich in rock
and sheep but it's poor in wheat brick
and wood so ideally you'd find a spot
with weak brick and wood oh look this
spot right here oh cool thank you
that's a good spot am i in the right
house yes
see
yeah thank you
you're doing great
the tan is all about coffee literally
built two cities you're doing phenomenal
andrew yeah would be very proud of you
and that's a good spot for you
thank you
this is a great spot
but then you don't have any wood
right but you trade it in for something
else
you could just be clay daddy honestly
i prefer [ __ ]
[ __ ]
but i'm getting your sheep lord
okay
you're sheep i'm
this is four seven eight this is
no i would i don't know what i'm doing i
don't know
okay i think you should just go here
because that that way you're not [ __ ]
up the other elise
okay
okay so uh you pick up these three
resources
you get a wood a hay and a clay
the clay
hay clay wood hey yes and then hey clay
would happen
just one oh yeah
you're good
there you go oh nice
you're doing great
thank you
yep
and let the games begin should we roll
in the box yeah
yeah just put it put it right here and
just roll into it lean over a little bit
seven seven oh can we explain sevens
there we go let's do a little seven
primer
you were talking about how we can do
this yeah so you can cover anything
cover something valuable cover one of
the red spots because the red spots are
the most valuable come on blue you're
blue so you don't want to cover up your
own spots but here you can cover this
this
this
that one looks good whoever you put it
near you also good to see you what do
you want to talk about look at these
people in the eye and choose one of them
that you want to punish
yeah i'm not on any red squares i'm just
saying
yeah i've honestly just had a rough day
so yeah i mean
well then you put it right here
at least
but i don't want
[Laughter]
have you ever done
yeah one card look at my cards and you
just grab one
perfect now it's here no it's your card
now it's yours
congratulations
yeah also somebody roses
and then build a road
correct half of them
build the road
right here
and give up a brick and mortar like
you're playing two places
you should have her and garrett to be a
team
[Laughter]
it shows you what costs a thing
yeah it's all kind of bricks you just
put it there and then
and it's like the chunk of it right and
you win by having so like every little
house is worth a point so you have two
points right now those houses are worth
two points having the longest road is
worth points and stuff like that and you
win by having 10. okay so yeah these two
points so put down the wood and the
brick back in the pile
what color is this it's great i'm green
i haven't had okay
who's orange you're orange
i'm gonna have to [ __ ]
red
rules
another seven b to b sevens
oh you rolled seven too damn yeah
anyone want wheat and have wood
do you want rock and what wood
[Music]
don't be sorry
uh the good thing is if he whispers to
you we're definitely all gonna hear it
the drunkest guy
yeah don't be creepy shut up hans dude
[ __ ] your office is kind of creepy
suck my dick dude what is that supposed
to mean man i'm not creepy no i'm just
kidding yeah you're not creepy you're a
good guy i try to be well okay i'm just
hammer drunk right now
okay so at least you got that one yeah
yeah put them up
make sure you know
what you're looking at
okay
where are you at what color are you blue
is there just two sixes expansion right
yeah there's just two sections right
okay
i don't know
you're good right now i
i just had to assess my
situation so i set her off on a track of
building a road here so she could build
a settlement here which is literally
half of my settlement
threes three i get wheat
and i'm going to do a whole lot of
nothing so you gotta get set up here you
got nine yeah you know four you got
eight three let's go i got more weeds
and then what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
trade since i have a port okay
um this is what it is i'm going to get a
what is this
i'm going to get a wood and a brick and
i'm just going to make a road so [ __ ]
makeup is probably mine i'll get it
right now
i'm going to build over right there
um it's just me
it's already starting again that's fine
i'm losing i'm going to feel it already
like i'm not even you okay yep i'm done
yeah okay seven
ten
oh man
can you hear me
i'm buying a death card
you're doing great
it's all about confidence
this is the guys
that sounds like no you didn't get it
they rolled the six hours
right now
oh wait did you roll the six oh can i
grab some wood oh sheep a pineapple
pineapple holy [ __ ]
what expansion are you playing that's
crazy it's very exclusive
um okay in your
that
turn
have
but in your journey okay i'm done
thank you
shut up shut up almonds
this is your [ __ ] number eight oh that's
good for us
that's right walk your ass back to your
village
does anyone want rock and have wheat who
has wheat
you got that break though i don't have
any brick
well i'll take a rock for a week
thanks man i'm just doing it
i appreciate it
that's my tragedy
you son of a [ __ ] what are you gonna
do he's always doing something
he's always doing something
how it works you know
no i don't know how it [ __ ] works
explain it to me i've never played katan
before dude can you tone down the
aggression dude no i can't i'm sorry i'm
sensing a lot of toxic masculinity a lot
of dudes
[Music]
thank you
all right i'm going to build
you're doing great i'm doing great thank
you i feel great you should i feel
really good you're tied for second place
thank you you're building a settlement
awesome okay
you're going to want to build a
settlement here because she's coming in
hot yeah
[Music]
yeah you gotta be doing something yeah
doing some you know oh
the good thing about the 10 is that you
can play every turn
for [ __ ]
is that better
it you can see the board
now you're right
oh what a day today for you know
yeah
okay
again yes
you know that's always what i need it's
my port
once your videos um
i'm going to use the night card
can i hit that also
i agree
can you think it's going to go no full
rotation
oh i got another one no can you hand me
a wood please yeah i've got you oh we
have two woods actually always a roll
damn eleven minutes thank you and eleven
does anyone have any directions for sale
uh
thank you for the weed
you're welcome
sorry
i have more gave it to gareth
it's not like i'll ever reciprocate
shut up gareth
shut up
y'all's turn
so we got white coming in hot and heavy
and i shouldn't say that but we got
black blue coming in with a fiery speed
towards this one
that's a good role so pick um what i
would do is [ __ ] over hans what does he
why would you do that points right now
you guys are he's falling for the
peacocking shut up you're trying to be
it's a good spam i'm tied for winning
so don't say that
but you also have to think about what's
the best spot in general this non nine
wouldn't work from the game
from nothing means nothing okay that's
what you're basically getting into right
now
however hans has something for no one
let's see
cover it
[Music]
saying no you can't take some white
elise at least you can't take from why
there's steel wait yeah you can no you
can't i don't have a house there so
you're he's correct so you're only
putting this settlement
that doesn't take hand
just take one card from his hand take
take one card there you go nice picture
good good that's your hat what do you
got i felt it i didn't even look at it
it's a rock it's alright
we saw it it was backwards shut up wow
covering up the valuable bricks spot
four dots
an interesting choice
but i'm sure gareth has elise's best
interest in mind hey you know what hans
suck a dick dude six
six who wants rock oh you should see
some wood
how many sir
you have something right here oh [ __ ] i
didn't even see that there was it there
the whole time no
i put it there recently i was gonna say
i didn't see that either so sometimes
just to pull yourself up by your
bootstraps [ __ ] moments hey can i hit
that join by any chance
yeah
okay
who wants rock
i'm down for what brick and wheat
what the [ __ ] or break or wait give you
a single week before a single wheat
anyone else have brick here
this is good stuff it's like
nice try i'll be going
who wants
no i'm getting good
wood for wheat
market's closed out
all right
closing bell just straight yeah you're
going down that's what for wheat the
thing is
i would give you great next time i get
some wheat that you need then you can
because i don't have any wood i just
realized that the only wood i gave
myself was this 11. right now
mm-hmm
three sir
i get two bricks
[Music]
all day
does anybody have a sheep they would
like to trade for anything
i'll trade you a sheet for wood
do you have a wood i have a wood oh no
never mind i was thinking the other way
around i asked if anyone had a sheep
they'd like to trade
what is your drunk ass saying right now
actually
you're smoking weed right now
no this uh
this thing is not hitting and also it
burned my lip but then the one you want
to get the bomb right there
yeah yeah i got you dog
well i can't even hear the one okay no
you know the one you're one hitter
yeah i know my one here why is that so
funny to you i broke it
i'm sorry dude you broke my 100 yeah i
did i i need to get you a new one
i'm sorry
the other night it's not even mine it's
rachel's
space that's six is another one
variables of threes okay
[Music]
you don't have to show us your arrogant
ass wait we don't show you one no
they're supposed to be hidden
but then oh i thought it says reveal the
car on the turn if with it you reach the
number of oh sorry y'all no
you got nine you're like yo does anyone
want to trade does anyone have any
he was on top of it the market was open
you weren't running
do they have a vagina word for that for
some things
pocket [ __ ] dude it's very immediate
we've been over this 100 times man
damn
damn
[Music]
i can't even build any settlements i
thought i was going to [ __ ] that around
like i'm already basically
i thought i was [ __ ] that thing
but no it wasn't what was happening
i was just like no i wouldn't
[Music]
let's respect the box
don't block the box you know
i'm walking there you cracked me up
riley pulled up outside vulcan and you
grabbed this out of him oh god damn
does that do anything
no oh i don't know if i have a longest
road technically can you can she still
build here
he wants um a very interesting move by
alicia
no no she can right there's no house
there it's within two out of two spaces
eight i'm um i roll the date
i'm building a city
it's breaking straight stuff so that's a
good uh
sheep or whatever
and a very very funny comedian
uh how did you feel about today's uh
kiltonian what is some of the craziest
things you've seen on the job i love the
wow
uh
today yeah it seemed like a pretty good
day like i mean
show wise yeah
but that one guy got in a fight
i was at the after party there was that
guy
yeah you were there for that again
i was gonna fight that guy
hey hans i'll still fight you dude does
anyone have a brick for a week actually
before i break for a week
[Laughter]
no you gotta
oh that's good that's good get that
stuff what do you got hold on we're
going to tell you guys something
yourself
you know what's happening
what's up
hey relax
i couldn't build a house right here you
know right because they're happening oh
yeah
two two away yeah i'm like four roads
away from never building a settlement
okay build a road here and it's gonna be
on the other end of this so
it's not even gonna be a difference
breaking the wood like one
okay
so
you're blue
so
phil garcia
a very historic comedian from detroit or
downtown
you uh you have a lot of connections
with uh
the dallas comedy club
once
yeah
i don't know the only time i performed
there was opening for you
and then previously when it before was
dallas comedy club it was dallas comedy
house yeah so
you came down with like genevieve and
right turns down all these detroit
yeah it's been i realized today it's
been like eight months since i've been
uh
two i've gone up three times in a row
and haven't been on it
yeah i got 499 500 and 501.
it was a good time
what was the number you get a number
[ __ ] develop that into okay being
interviewed whatever
[Music]
so what do you like about the awesome
comedy scene
are you asking me still
yeah phil
i don't i like i don't
other comedy scenes probably have this
but this happens more regularly than
austin than any other comedy scene i've
been a part of what is that
thing yeah right the party morning it's
a very social thing yeah that's probably
it's a community for sure people like
each other here
that's the thing that people don't
understand
yeah our last look comfortable is that
it haunts us yeah so you have nice
happy times alone do you think it's
expensive to live here every all my
friends from like everywhere else in
texas really oh it's awesome
dfw houston
okay it cost me as much to live here as
it did in huntsville texas
huntsville you lived in huntsville i
went to school you [ __ ] lived
in huntsville let's go
[Music]
you're raising the temperature of the
room and it's really i'm gonna build a
settlement i should buy mela
i swear to god dude i'm gonna fry your
marshmallow right now dude i swear is
that a sexual thing
[Music]
right how many yeah it's your return
though this is the new settlement that
i've been all put down yeah how many
other cards is it's four right
with four yeah i got three by the way
congratulations
where's your
i know i'm having an underwhelming game
things aren't going our way what's your
color at least you know the robber
bricks you too we just fired her you
took my position
we just fired our head coach so
god [ __ ] damn it yeah i can do that
i'm gonna do another development card
you better win rojo i got you dude
[Music]
yeah i felt that
you have to say it i i will every time
five
oh again thank you
i know that's might be the first one
that is the first one who's white you
got it
you got one breaks orange did you grab a
ball where does anyone want it for i'll
pay you five dollars
is the light on or off
i'm really confused yeah why don't you
be in charge of the light you're all
dying
okay every seven minutes i'm gonna turn
11 and another oh
another 11 you get 11. yeah
okay sharks who has a break
for
uh
for a wheat or sheep
oh
sheep
you're choosing
you say no orange how about both huh
what are you doing are you serious i'm
gonna give you two cards
no huh did you have a break connectivity
no what about you did you have a brick
for me
just say no
i'll give you this victory point
for the for those reasons i'm out all
right
traded you this whole university card
for two brick right now
don't don't don't lose the box guys
let's not talk to the box can we fix
that and post the box except for here
right now
and then yeah
bro what [ __ ] oh my god
i have the
box once has a victory point
and leave this one over here yes there
we go
we're good enough
oh i'll take it at seven
well then you get to move move that
bus put it over all he's winning it
didn't land right in the box put it
through
okay great we decided
how was your depth that works it's still
a three
it's not very good
right the box is right
four
eight that's a good one
oh we like that stone
good lord we like that a lot there it
is
sorry
got wood for sale
blah's really he's balls winning right
now
he's low-key winning
mm-hmm but he's like a sound assassin
okay
no build a settlement right here
that you could do that dude you should
do that right now yeah lucy i don't know
if she has enough cards for that
you're going to do that
you'll [ __ ] yourself okay yeah you do
yeah what's happening you're sorry
shut up hans [ __ ] you
what do you think you know more because
you're [ __ ] more productive than
asian is that what it is dude
i think you just were wrong right then
no like you did the wrong thing and it's
embarrassing no
i agree though sorry i'm better so good
wait didn't someone roll seven oh no she
wrote it
who wants this
i do i do
two weeks i have one week two weeks
for just a break i need
two weeks we shoot for
um
okay
thank you you're right you got three
maybe i should have been more careful
appreciate it thank you oh well
oh comment once uh do you have any more
cbd measures
yeah i think you have a problem
you know i think you might be right
what's solid on this right this podcast
right now
delta nine
um
orange
two
yeah
oh my god below is winning so hard
damn it dude
um
[Laughter]
i'm trying to think i don't even know if
i can honestly every single time he's
just a mathematician or something
i don't understand
all right so i'm gonna do another
development card
wow
oh my god
wow what was that guy saying
was that was that the whole thing was
that it was just like i just need my
credit in debit cards
four times it was so dumb no no the
thing was apparently he like uh pushed
one of the guys inside so that's why he
got kicked out
[Music]
he tried to come back in four times
before he got tough two times
can he break
how did that happen how do you
get this
does anyone want to trade a rock for a
week or a year
for a week who came up to me and was
like a what who are you where is she and
i love you
some guy came up to you or a rock and a
shoe i love you man i don't know who you
are but i really like you and i was like
guy is just [ __ ] like he has no
legitimate
excuse for asking me because i just came
up to him and i was like
what are you [ __ ] saying
it was like what are you talking about
okay it's a
[Music]
don't do it
[Music]
have you rolled yet
that's my rule what is it oh you rolled
a seven yeah so i'm going to build the
road
[Music]
one two three four five one two three
yeah you have longest row
six
uh
i don't know because whoever is white
[Music]
you just put them that way wow did you
pay any attention to the rest of kill
tony yeah i was i was up uh next to the
stage the whole time
i got to see you i'm building it for the
most part
i was asleep i had something a great
view of the [ __ ] stairway so i was
like i have nothing to do here
i'm not allowed in the water no
it's like a commercial though with the
back light and everything i actually
kind of do want some water
i wish
like you don't want to smoke a cigarette
oh you just smoked this yeah
[Music]
no i lost a pack earlier today because
yeah you lost the pack earlier too and i
just found it for you no legitimately
you don't know if that was the one you
brought in here
uh probably couldn't yeah
[Music]
comedy
drink my kids
wait what happened to them
nice
what happened to this
and got stolen from the seven so you're
mr rogers there's three other cards
though hold on they're trying to open
the door just
keep going
you traded with me one
and he's still there
well i didn't respond my thumbs like him
oh [ __ ]
christy you [ __ ] dude what's up
christina
off camera all right
um all right yeah
that's so good
i'm still out of breath
[Music]
okay so who's who rolled
um
this is a cool setup
thanks this is my chill vibes yeah it's
actually better
don't say that below is right here
[Laughter]
why would you say that hans i don't
understand
what
[Music]
let's go
yeah your turn
all right the button down
gracie
11.
[Music]
um does anyone want a tree is
the whole thing
i might
yo dude i don't think so like no i
actually made fun of this guy that when
we were playing beer pong with the cave
i was like
i beat him and then i'm gonna when i hit
him on the last cup i was another five
what are you abercrombie and finch and
then him and his friend were wearing
ambergris revenge and his eyes i know no
one has rock based off of yeah i won ski
mountain dudes
yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah
ski mountains
[Music]
absolutely yeah 100 you can't need
right now or to move that
wait what seven what's going on right
now
uh i'm done it's not my turn
all right
for a wood and then in your journey
you gotta build you got to build a brick
that's those people over here
do you want to just play by yourself are
you do you want care to help you or not
no i don't
don't help her you said he was gonna
help me yeah
so you helped me with this yeah
if you see that thing i just feel blue
blue jackets that's really annoying
what color are you white
how did you get so much rock
how was this vulcan today it was pretty
good pretty cool that's pretty chilly
bathroom yeah yeah
anyways christy why you had to just like
your turn
[Music]
women's restrooms are way worse
monopoly's heart
with this monopoly card i back and forth
all your weeds they sew it upon me
peasants
oh man don't look i don't have any
what time is it
it's game time
i'm gonna go home
bye
you know what
it's three o'clock i can't do anything
here
no right within this game
and i feel like uh blah's gonna win
wow you're gonna win dude
i think you should like
go to the nearest liquor store break in
and find his booze that's your mission
and i come back here and then we all get
hammered and then we can understand i
think i have a bottle of tequila in my
trunk honestly
really can you get it please
i'm dying over here
let's go garrett this is the rehab
circle i like really yeah right
we can do it tomorrow
we're doing this game
okay
i got to get up at like
7 00 am tomorrow
come on all right is it already over
[Music]
uh no there's like a few more wait i
can't i can't build here right it's
gonna be two away from one of them
so you can just fill them
[Music]
a stupid road
that's all i can do i can't even throw
like a kink in other people's plans
they're stupid
my game is going right now
why you have to throw kinks around dude
i'm not ashamed does anybody have a
sheep for a brick
i will i will do it
that's too easy boy
[Music]
um i'm gonna go on the side right now
that's illegal
i know you can't not mention anything
with that
okay
three
four
times that's very serious
six
does anyone have any bricks
no one has any brick they want to give
up
it's ally's turn okay
you have to speak up more like you know
mm-hmm
um it's good
it's also just like a road at this point
which is pointless
yeah i'm the one for the rock roads are
amazing i have wouldn't see it from
wood and sheep so they're actually very
pointless right
but i mean
yeah don't have no that brick i'm right
all right does anyone have
any wheat
i have sheep and wood
for wheat
so then i am going to get a trigger
that's a pillow
a special pillow for the net yeah that's
my turn
all right okay
except for the future
shut up yes
[Music]
i have anything you want
including hand stuff
i think that was you breathing
shut up
anybody won't break for anything no
one's cleaning it going once
you're putting areas please relax
all right i'm gonna build two roads
this is just try not to break it
okay
i'm gonna do that
why do you have oh yeah why
what [ __ ] why do you have memento
everywhere
what is this
what is this hans what are you trying to
remember oh that's like a phrase it's uh
i've seen something like this
my favorite director ever momento bori
i was like going crazy
it's like the third time i've seen it
five five's only three i'm gonna
shoot
five
oh five let's go
oh [ __ ] more i can do it now oh okay
who's turn
who just rolled the five at least
okay did you you oh you rolled the five
yeah that's all right
now it's weird yeah move it
move it
you have to get rid of half your cards
right true yeah
yeah isn't that everyone have these
networks
i just no one's reminded anyone all game
you have to get rid of half your cards
because you roll to seven
if you have seven or more oh okay
[Music]
one two
three four five dude that pillow was set
dude
if you were telling a girl to like
um wiggle her boobs you could be like
move that bust
you know chant that while she was like
oh my god so vulgar
oh christy my christian sensibilities
wow does your neck feel so good and
supported and like what hey
you didn't move it yet oh [ __ ] what did
you roll
seven oh okay
are you [ __ ] kidding me dude you're
winning get up um over at the um
what did you get on the mic over at um
creek in the cave at the end the other
night
today no power hour
three
i get a week really
say three
yeah it's the last one before amy goes
back to new york uh
dang
hans is forever
not forever she'll be back um
anybody have any rock they would like to
trade dude i haven't seen one of those
in a minute man
yeah i wish all the rocks are like
you're building let me know all right
okay all right
let me see
all three of us are tied for longest
road this year
here oh
he pulls ahead
we might need a sponsor along this road
this doesn't count as the longest show
because it's interrupted by the
settlement okay all right
is that true i think so then why
wouldn't you be able to build that and
i don't know
you don't think that she should can you
google it no i don't think that's dead i
mean i don't think so because i built
the road first and then she put down the
stuff like i own that part first if she
did want to put a sun in there so it's a
road before it's a settlement does
anybody have any water they want to
trade for brick
you're good
i saw you relax truly for a second i saw
you cradle your drums
yeah i'll do that for you say it to my
face
[Music]
he didn't have a neck when he first got
it
yeah he is such a
yeah you don't have any yeah you can't
do that
yeah you gotta turn into a city oh
that's stupid
i'm never playing this game again all
right i'm gonna take my uh
brick
i feel like arizona playing world of
warcraft what do you think about casey
rocket and how he's the future of
comedy gray i love casey yeah he just
did my favorite second phillip lawyers
pure comedy it's just
it's in
no i watched him tonight over at uh
shakespeare's and there's like nobody
paying attention to anybody and then he
went on
videos wait what time did he
we're turning up all right i mean i
went up there was no five again that's
why but everybody was paying attention
the point is when casey went up i'm
gonna build a road
yeah because it's like he can't fail
even when he's failing he's doing good
this does well dude it's ridiculous
because he's just feeding off the energy
he's like hell yeah he knows the rhythm
like he finishes the punchline and
he carries over the uh
he does a good job of creating the
energy that he's following though too
like it's like a pretty even push and
pull i would say i've seen him turn dead
rooms into live rooms exactly man that's
what i'm saying man it's incredible it's
just
when people are explaining something can
you let them explain it instead of
saying that's incredible yeah wow
amazing well [ __ ] you hans okay i have
your neck pillow on right now and i feel
a little bit more uh
cautioned
he's all like he's always on but then he
like i used him on my podcast he brought
grimace pictures
right up front and then at the end he
like we talked about who he really was
and then we had by the end of it we were
riffing again so it was cool to see him
kind of
not on for a good like 30 minutes or so
he's such a nice guy yes one of the
friendliest comics
yeah but he has like boundaries and
walls
he like
doesn't want to get too close to you
sometimes
yeah
he respects boundaries
so whose turn
someone out here
i'm an official
i looked it up about the settlement in
the road i
this picture is incriminating just
looking at it i know man you should have
saw my face like three days ago
sorry about any hardships that you faced
because of a zoning game
did you roll already yeah i wrote a five
again
what's your standalone dinosaur all
righty are you garrett gareth from uh
from texas
six
so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to
we want to what should we put on the tv
[Music]
does anyone need
just for the audio
do you need sheep below no
there's a bar like that that did an open
mic and yeah i don't have anything so
you need to play
during the open like that's
[Music]
[Music]
that's a great job right all right yeah
[Music]
[Music]
and they're building in all those high
rises too
whereas they say spanish being countries
says
what a race are you casa
yeah i went to montclair state i was
gonna either go to rutgers or my dad
went there so i was born here but then i
moved to seattle when i was seven uh did
you you did stress factory i asked him
or
i wish
the first ever open like i did was that
stress factor i brought like 15 people
because it's a bringer show and we get
there and the host is like we're
canceling the mic
you guys never bring anyone this is my
first set ever and it was just canceled
it was a temper tantrum oh yeah just
cancel show and i just went to new york
the next day and did uh what's the stan
the stan or stand up there yeah i'm like
80th and
eight or whatever the [ __ ] anyways
living the dream how have you been doing
he always notices when someone dodges a
question and he really did just notice
that like
[ __ ]
what's your ethnicity i mean i think
that thing might miss you right both of
my parents are from
music so are you kidding me palestinian
it's like this old place in the middle
east i get the points
yeah explain to me what it is well no i
mean if i tell anybody that they just
sometimes look at me like what the [ __ ]
is that yeah how dare you like this or
they say pakistan you're entertainment
just yeah it's just
wait do like
guys know something's hilarious i just
didn't waste time my turn it's your turn
now i just did the mic was it
shakespeare
sure shakespeare's and the host
i didn't know it was jewish or let alone
israeli was just fine but i did my whole
thing i did my whole bit and then as i
was getting off she was just like
yelling at me rejoice about how i was
wrong and i was just israeli and then i
had to call my mom i was like mom have
you been lying to me am i jewish like
what's going on
i just thought it was funny are you
gonna do anything else i have a video i
have a video of it it's so funny because
it cuts out the perfect time
for being like no no you've got me
eight
oh rock on the game
made that same mistake my first set here
in austin because she used to host that
whistle pig or whatever it is
pouring rain and i made a joke about how
they were going to talk about that
stick
and then
she was like i'm jewish you know when i
was like oh
so i was wondering like why like she's
doing she's like right well she's a
musician
it doesn't matter
no i know but i just thought that was
kind of scary to act that way
no i know i was just like
i don't know that's what it was all
right that makes sense
i just thought it was so i thought it
was funny it's a [ __ ] open mic i
don't understand why it's not like
someone walked up and was like it could
have been 12 million you know what i
mean yeah
yeah i definitely felt gaslighted but
it's all right all right just not gas
chambers
i'm just digging it deeper
yeah you know like a mask
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
we gotta
[Music]
wait
um let me see
[Music]
i'm kind of [ __ ] now what time he's
winning kareem jordan [ __ ] you kareem
kill yourself uh what color are you oh
well yeah
um and i'm gonna build
oh
[Music]
yeah
so you're right that means you win seven
now i think he's at seven right now
that's a ten
you said that you spoke that into
existence i really
uh yeah i'm done
all right
seven eight nine this is exactly what i
needed i get two bricks oh yeah oh yeah
now i'm gonna build a settlement
oh no i'm building
[Music]
no
if she puts it because this is me right
here
yeah i saw how you can't see the white
the white very well
right
so uh below what is your strategy here
you're going for this long winding road
you have to uh
build all these settlements you have no
rocks so you can't turn into cities
so you're kind of limited there how do
you feel about your game so far
i can't wait where did you put that to
shoot for wait whatever get into what
regardless
shoot per week
i'll take that for you
yeah thanks yeah i really appreciate it
man great team business
development cards
settlements i appreciate it stuck i like
playing i really did fast
this way yeah it's like i know you
haven't changed
i mean i have a pizza that we can make
in the oven
it's not deliveries
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because of the crazy [ __ ] they're saying
it's kind of like oh i like this
beautiful did i just give you that you
know some of them are beautiful and kind
of funny actually like a lot of them try
to be funny okay keep telling yourself
that
how many have actually transferred you
going out with them and hanging out well
it was just today
so first like time it was just today so
i was just like let's hang out to some
of them but then on tinder
i was gonna delete it because everyone's
trash
they said i changed it to six another
eight let's change it to people though
how'd that go
i hung out with the girls
how was that
do another um course she's like
pressuring you
into like yeah because gay people like
want it to be like
like not serious but they want it to be
right
yeah
and then
us straight people waddle in like
experimenting and we're wrong what do
you do you want to be here you don't
have patience for that
but it was fun she made patience
she made pages
where he was crazy
have a girl like talk to me
when and it's like she's interested in
me no i'm halfway there like you could
go that way
okay
[Music]
[Music]
very like
all right
open that up
the world is conspiring against
me yeah um wait does anyone have any
sheep for wood
ventilation
i'm telling you like for you like like
i'm saying like to go on a date with
like a same-sex person it opens up your
heart oh no yeah that was a good play
right there
yeah
i'll check it out let me just change
that's the issue
i don't know honestly dudes are
aggressive though so that might not go
well yeah you have to yeah i think if
you [ __ ] a dude you'd end up getting
people more yeah and then what about you
i'm talking about men yeah
yeah you dated a woman they're beautiful
they're like men are like
yeah know he's right if i was a chick i
was like you would validate all your own
worst thoughts this is what i was
getting at this whole yeah
i would be given the tax purposes
for the right offers
i would never
your heart is closed because you're like
no no
and so that's why i'm saying it opens up
your heart you're like okay
we like we're like fully connecting she
wants us to wrestle right now get her
she wants us to wrestle
that's how it always starts right just a
little wrestling or wrestling we'll
wrestle yeah dude
let's just take off our jackets
my nose touches your neck next thing
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is
are you from short hills or whatever
montclair i went to montclair state but
i'm from about 30 minutes north this
month
what's that montclair state how dare you
dude
i know right yeah i had to work in
montclair that's the same way you were
jelly on it right yeah i had to work in
the mall yeah
what the [ __ ] really yeah
you take the path
oh jersey people are the worst yeah i
mean not worse than massachusetts
butchers people are like
because they're not smart
sorry um
is
okay
um no one has any hate
that's your turn that's my turn
what the [ __ ] are you doing christy
someone oh here he sucks it back
six seven eight nine that's pretty easy
eight yeah eight yeah eight so
no [ __ ] [ __ ]
all your clothes are like folded up
right now
you might you're my favorite i'm five
nine i'm white jewish no [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm mad about i'm gonna trade these
you're a [ __ ]
and leave it there
put down this wood and build a road dude
that's like anxiety inducing there's
something sorry i feel like it's getting
off like why
is smoking a cigarette
all right
oh just kidding
all right i'm
trading in eight
eight woods
for uh for a sheep and a purple thing
and this for a dead card
cool just
uh
there you go
just take the dice
yeah this is only somebody sneaking up
behind me in the woods
you want to watch something something
like approaching
i hate that for whatever reason corbin
blue and the name will always remember
from that in front of that
like a six-year stint he did a bunch of
movies with disney i'm like why do i
know corbin blue versus like exactly
though that's crazy right
yeah cordon bleu i can't stand it you
don't like it with the chicken i think
it's disgusting yeah why would you put
hair i would have gotten out of my head
yeah that's true
and then fry it yeah who wants this
you have weight for what
i will give you nine sheep for that rock
yeah
whoa the way you
lied
but everyone did
that's crazy i wouldn't have thought
that's probably a character defect
no and philip garcia yeah but he just
like says numbers
for no reason how it did was it really
unbelievable why like did you felt like
they were i was like you must have a lot
of sheep like i do have a lot of sheep
but i really thought i was to give them
nine for one yeah i was like you must be
disgullable people
yeah quit getting on defensive back i
just don't want to be known as a liar
yeah
yeah
that's a very strong word
but christina's is very extreme
sometimes five
yeah
i don't know why i was blocking man is
only working five months blocked me
exactly
all right
i'm gonna trade up for breakfast really
yeah four five six i have six points if
only you had the sheep i have you could
go
dude if i had those sheep i would rule
the world
yeah so like what
euro meat
what like euro like food they say like
lamb
[Music]
for a year and then you kill it and so
it's still um
you kill it when it's stop doing that
what i can't my gaze just how do you
know how do you know these things
because i googled it at my side no no
it's not does anyone have hay that they
want to give me for any resources
because i didn't want to eat baby sheets
like those are so cute um maybe and then
i ate it and it was so any resources
that i was like i need to go i was like
okay i know that you guys eat lamb every
day so you don't relate no i mean i try
not to but
i don't know it was funny when i
literally went home to jersey my mom
one of the meals she made was a lamb
yeah
well yeah i mean they grow the sheep up
until they're an adult and then they
kill them
so
it's it's fine but the sheeps are cool
with it though right
i just didn't want people like tying
baby sheep down and killing yeah that's
not cool yeah that's not how they're
supposed to do it if it's like that but
don't they do that to on purpose to feel
because blood like yeah it's supposed to
be killed young that's true because
philip has the biggest army i don't eat
i've never had
i didn't know you were supposed to i
just wait to hold them and play them all
the same time but yeah i'll do it
wait two more turns to have loose you'll
be losing you're good so you move move
it then right to move the robber have
you already done that no because i wrote
an 11.
but did you play the night you played
tonight right oh you do yes you wrote it
and steal
please
don't do that to me
you need that
does anyone want to trade a sheep for a
wood
oh do you have something i have a sheep
i'm building this here
why and
good thing there's no families out
driving this lake
here we go
what is that
all right
does anyone have any sheep for wood
i'll give you a sheep
thanks
everyone's so nice here
development card
it's quiet in here too quiet
would you like to sit over here should i
play for gareth or no you just play for
me
oh
i mean i could play for garrison he
wasn't even playing was he yeah yeah you
can play
at least
how many buys man
there's 12
gareth is responding to my instagram
story right now
while driving
yo brother to the guy in there
he was like god that guy was gay
you know like you should be driving
right now okay
yeah are you also a sadler
what does that mean we're gonna walk in
this part of the car
i'm like
nervous because i feel like my makeup is
messed up and y'all are looking at me
closely i don't know you're fine
people are like yeah we can see here
i know a lot about makeup and where it
should be
yeah yeah
this podcast is actually all about
makeup
dude zach bogus is like a professional
at makeup and he like he'll like
suddenly tell me like you know how
[ __ ] up my makeup is but it's like
really mean
um makeup
he's like your eyebrows don't look real
at all where's his background in makeup
even
dude he was a makeup person at sephora
or at ulta like he's zach he's really
good yeah he looks like he would be
someone that does makeup at sephora it's
kind of yeah maybe i could totally see
him full face with glitter yeah he seems
like
um
once you hear that you're like okay
maybe yeah i can kind of see that
i think he should go back to ulta
because i need to hook up there
you guys don't you can't stomp on
people's heads
yeah
i just created
what i paid
for the credit card they give you
is
[Music]
i haven't played
[Music]
um
especially if you're wearing like yogurt
or something you wouldn't want like a
bulbs thing i don't know yeah but i
learned a long time ago if you go right
here there's no bulls
they're all the same in between
i hope the irs isn't watching this
that's actually where most of my bulge
is hey do any of you people have waited
people for you it might work yeah you
[ __ ] [ __ ] uh
[Music]
foreign
hey guys stop bonding anyone have any
right okay oh we actually for for what
what do you what do you want no you
start to win over yours or anything yeah
yeah shut the [ __ ] up no i actually like
them sabotaging me sorry i like the
weight that i have oh you like the
okay you don't need anything nothing at
all sometimes you got the wheat that you
got all right one
six six
and i'm gonna play a knife
and you get to move that yeah
[Music]
was your ex-girlfriend um one of the
perpetrators of the genocide
or one of the victims of the genocide
victim she was actually a fled refugee
we lived in germany for a little bit and
then you got a sponsored family
so yeah
uh no no her family stayed together they
found sponsor families in germany
because they were refugees and then
in
[Music]
it's like
between russia and western europe really
does anyone have
yeah does anyone have any bricks they
would like strategies
anyone needs sheep
all right well i'm going to take three
sheep for a break because i have a port
now
so i'm gonna get a break
i'm gonna build a road
but yeah i mean slavs were the original
slaves
yeah i told my little sister that my
little sister for her whole life just
thought that she was a
bet the best white people like the
nordics she's always thought that
and then i was like you're actually
sloppy
like hitler denied you guys
yeah like showed her the articles and
everything i was like yeah y'all are
sloppy
sorry
i know you're mad at me already too but
i hope this is still pretty cool
but i listened to the leopold like
episodes today you didn't roll yet
though
y'all could be born in another race
that hasn't been rolled all game i think
my race is pretty good
yeah or i would just ecuadorian
getting raped by conquistadors like well
in this day and age i'm like one of the
hottest people like you know mostly
white yeah i like
it that makes sense
huh good fan would i be possible
oh yeah pig roasts
does anyone have a sheep for a wood be a
defensive lineman yeah
[Music]
wow
three sheep
so we don't have anything the wheat gods
there's no question finally coming dude
there's nothing we can do
you can go
but yeah when you think about what race
you want to be it's like it gets pretty
weird
what about you if you had to choose a
different race for your next life
with the current with the current
politics
i want to be jewish
yeah which one though like some of them
are gross some of them are hot some
there's jews all over the place
um
[Music]
yeah we're now
tied to play she's my puppet's name
elise is my puppets
she's ukraine okay
what does that mean i mean i'm
supporting her
it looks like she's in charge but i'm
secretly behind the scenes guys
dude
yeah
like peanut she's gonna go down these
rabbit holes i want to smoke a cigarette
and i'm and i'm hunter by this oh
does anybody have any wheat that would
like to trade for anything
anymore
nobody has any
[Music]
you see what he did he's been
gaslighting us do you see what he
[ __ ] do no he's winning he's i'm
tired i just barely caught up he's been
at seven points this whole game
he's jeff bezos then again he also has
three of those cards
does anyone have any rock they will give
me for wood or sheep
trading should be closed what aren't she
do you have any wheat
i have
sheep oh what did you roll you said you
had wood and [ __ ] no i i have wooden
shoes
two stupid all day she doesn't i don't
think she is
[Music]
yeah you can't play the card you get the
turn up right yeah you can play another
card though
well i'm gonna play a robber i'm
still from
who has good wheat
sorry dude
dude
so they can do nothing
which way which way did you not want me
to build it you can only build a
settlement here because this wouldn't
block you so put your road over here so
that you then
i'm just going for the longest route i
can't believe this
please respect the box
yeah
all right my turn
another
for anything
yes
you guys want to see the latest football
highlights
sure
i'm gonna
trade in these three because i have a
port
no matter what happens on the field i
don't care
but it's interesting
i guess if somebody kills someone else
or whatever then no one knows two games
how can you die
i think it's cool to go there and see
everybody getting mad at each other holy
[ __ ] more to hockey than just getting
mad at it i play hockey awesome ice
cream
yeah dude
do you play with alex
i play in a beer league
uh i don't know who that is
i'm gonna buy two dev cards but uh back
east when the pawns would freeze that's
what that's what you would do you would
go play hockey you'd get hot you could
find trump yeah exactly would anyone
want to get through you would freeze
uh those palestinians ice skating again
i know my my cousin whose little name is
that would be hilarious played hockey
would bring me to games
to see like somebody in full black garb
like
11.
okay wait that's actually funny
that's pretty serious that's kind of
like the mummy on ice though if you
think about it your turn
can you give me the dice thank you
oh
yeah
yeah
she hot on ice
[Music]
dude
[Music]
[Music]
over this table
did you feel more connected to society
all right then i'm gonna pass it off i
kind of want to smoke a cigarette right
now because i'm getting kind of on edge
i can tell yeah you should embrace your
eggs
no this isn't good edge
ball needs to be i just want this game
to be over us damn
it's taking too long because we keep
getting sidetracked and returned dude
but if i don't smoke a cigarette then
you can get all the conversation out
wait no and then when i get back we'll
be ready to buckle down for the second
it's like halftime so you think that
you're in charge because you're winning
what are you talking about no he has
biggest army i just want to smoke a
cigarette
you can police yeah i've got the biggest
army there pawns i'm going to steal from
you dude
does anyone have any wheat they want to
give me
for rock or
sheep or wood
there is a wheat shortage would to give
you for a wheat
i will give you wood no
i need wheat whoa he really did a dance
ugh
what's wrong about that
i just was not expecting that
they practiced it i'm gonna play
monopoly yeah yeah i am invoking what
did you say last time the power of
another one like that yeah i just want
everyone's wheat right now [ __ ]
in a row
[Music]
that's crazy let me tell you that's a
game changer for me so
that's pretty [ __ ] wow
can i play two nights in one turn no
okay okay he's got a largest army now
though yeah yeah he's got five points
six
says
all right
so you know we weren't lying to you so
we're gonna trade yeah you know we
weren't lying to you know what i'm gonna
trade at least three
yeah i mean i'm gonna trade these three
four weeks i guess that's a nice
validation because i have a porch
[Music]
[Music]
trade
these three kills
he's uneasy
he's a living chico yeah and that's all
i love does anyone want to trade i have
a wood
dude what the [ __ ] all right your turn
that's every possible number that could
happen right now it's a nine
i get three bricks
that help you i'm sorry you're the
detroit lion
we don't talk about those people yeah
the black men
oh that's it
we all are happy about matt stafford
going to the super bowl then right yeah
that's why i made the joke i was like
i've made so many friends from detroit
this year i'm happy matt stafford's
going to the super bowl
y'all talk about them like people talk
about like
dads that got pushed out of the house by
abusive models
he's a good dad you know they just
couldn't take care of him
[Music]
happy and be like hey guys how was it
take your time yeah you're like
another one
what about moss
yeah
i just knocked my car
all right who wants brick
i do what do you want what
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me you said
last time you said it was whoever said
it first
he didn't say it first he said it he did
say first
you need to go
slow
all right i'll draw cards for you all
right thanks yeah and uh wait it's my
turn next though
who wants to do it again
okay
for what
i will trade you one break i'll tell you
what
he's like get
what about sheep
or wheat
there's no wheat
it's not it's not a personal thing it's
a truth
um let me just build a road and then
here
actually i'll just save it up
again
i mean you can wear in the class so
philippines
no i got a class in laredo oh in the
next four hours don't say too much it's
like you're on the internet right now
is class fun
and
somewhere i'm mostly
online like two in-person classes what
are they
um it's like research methods of
research and development and the other
one is um
it's not public relations that's online
i had to take theater history once
even though i didn't want to it was the
worst thing what did you take last
semester we had to watch all the david
ladies david lynch
a cigarette for a rock
wait is that legal follow me google that
is it native american very good deal no
one
serious illegal to trade
so no one's got wheat that's the that's
the name of the game
no one just has no one has wheat at all
no uh maybe no
okay well i'm gonna play this night and
find out i want to rob it from you
who you robbed me yeah
sorry statistically yeah
is
did you fan them all out or
no no these are my all right so i'm
gonna go to the room
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
that's two roads
and i'm going to get a third road people
all got brick
oh my gosh
did you get clips below you got two you
got two bricks
so i got three ropes
three fourteen damn look at that road
one two three four five six seven eight
nine eleven twelve thirteen fourteen so
you get the
longest road
wow sheesh
that's sick well i mean you had an
opportunity that's why
everyone in the center just [ __ ]
themselves
their civilizations
they're forgetting what their traditions
are at this point
we don't even know where we are oh my
god
half of your cards dude oh yeah yeah
we're on the seven
so it's anyone who has seven or over
so everyone has to get rid of half their
cards do you have seven
people
does he have seven he has more than
seven does he have to get rid of one of
these is a but you're picking one first
one of these is that true one of these
is that they have to get rid of them
first yeah
and then you pick from him look he's
like yeah that makes us confused yeah
that is morning that's a lot more than
so yeah yeah it's like 15 and he goes
one of them's a development card like
[ __ ] right
it's more than seven it's how many ones
whose turn is there right now
what is it
right so it's six if it's eleven six
cards discarded yeah or no no or it's
might be is that five
if he has eleven how many cards does he
discard six or five five five squared
five you've been seeing
elise she was on kill tony today
this is the hans king faithful or the
one
waiting
yeah
himself
what would you say that
i go with myspace you're a comedian how
did you like kill tony tonight was it
was it fun did you enjoy the being on
stage park that's the first time you've
been on it right yes
it was the first time i've been on stage
and the kill tonight
uh
i thought it was all right
like i don't really did she get
up or didn't did she i'm not trying to
get too uh
put you know two in my head over that
yeah you know i'm just yeah like
did you get your bra
no i need to take from yeah
what i did this game going and i
mentioned that i had sex all right
i said we met at a comedy show
development card all right
it was uh
yeah
i think it was good it's 4 15 when
there's a kill tony show around you when
you're with hans cream out of kill time
yeah we're going to be called up on
stage
i know i wasn't prepared one time
i'm in a good spot whoever wants to take
me over and i did let's all try on it
yeah
you just need to keep upgrading thank
you for coming please come again of
course thank you i had fun i'm walking
down
oh
yeah
did you just go
um no not yet
yeah i actually know what i just said
but
um
with elise's
turn bye
yeah like what is this
this is his i guess
yeah he doesn't respect the box at all
yeah
you must respect the box
he also is a big
guy like he's always trying to do
loopholes
so it's really warming
it just reminds me of like
who's blue
the white people pick up here
signed all the contracts and stuff like
i think it's just stealing territory
from indigenous people can i like
upstate myself and it seems like he's
those are his ancestors we're almost
done okay okay
six
but uh this is a different angle to be
what did we roll
i put down a settlement
ellie's looks like a competitive person
she's like i could push it so far
i build a settlement
and i have a victory point and i have
10. two one
i want you to know i have one of those
two i didn't ever get to put down but i
have it we all knew you had it it was on
the scoreboard of a gun
i was about to take back on this road
i wish you could have made it a little
bit more climactic when you won
yeah i'm not gonna stay for this
yeah
yeah yeah i have this so that's it
all right good night hans thanks for
having us
how do you think the show went tonight
and i thought it went great
i thought tony was super funny i thought
dave smith was super funny
observations yeah
absolutely that was a good guess yeah
yeah
he left right after the show i didn't
see him at all
right after the show i thought he was he
was in there for a second i think maybe
he was just on stage he didn't come back
to the green room
again
well there's six people so we'd have to
do at least
best out of 52.
until one person gets an advantage
because it could technically
be
best out of three four five
yeah is that that math where you do an
exclamation point or something
it would be up to thirty would be at
least
30 games that's 31 games two two
imaginary numbers
no that's not what that is
what is that called it is like
not free radicals are like
free radicals
that's what i am
i hate how much this [ __ ] football in
the background like triggers my
reptilian mind i'm just like oh they're
cheering
yeah
it triggers my miserable memories okay
let's watch something that brings us
happiness joy you see but you like
yeah i like watching men do amazing
things
against other men
you don't like what you what you don't
like watching people express themselves
physically and run around really fast
most of what they're doing is walking
around showing the coach
showing a commercial like that's most of
it yeah but then for like five seconds
the most physically fit specimens in the
world throw themselves at full speed
cool like i'm trying to move a ball a
couple feet yeah but i can't even see
their faces
but you can see their tight asses in
those pants right they're watching rugby
it's like
i don't know
i once had a man try to tell me the
longest joke about football ever and i'm
gonna just know that the punch line was
something like yeah it was just about
some ditsy girl who's like i just don't
know why they
fight all that time over a coin toss
i was just thinking did you really just
take 15 minutes to tell me this joke
feels bad
worse than that there you go i actually
think that's kind of funny it's like
they're just fighting about the coin
toss
i like the type pants and i like all the
ball stuff but i just don't know why
they fight over a coin toss for a whole
hour
no but it is kind of gay that you guys
really choose for them to like
bend over in tight pants like that no i
just wish my parents
this is an argument we had one time as
you were like yoga pants on girls as an
intentional sexual ploy and i was like
no it's actually just the best way to
move so people like them like and that's
a thing
like i just want basketball to make them
wearing shorts too
i wonder why someone who's worn football
pants i think they're the worst thing
for the job though to be honest with you
other than the material like it's nice
on turf but they were just the most
uncomfortable pants you could ever wear
flip mobility was constantly that's
because you have guts hanging out of
your body but we don't
yeah yes christy why are you so
confrontational because i just real i
realized
i realized the points
you try to bring everyone up instead of
sound oh really
yeah i guess i'm just like trying to
argue about how i take the balls
[Music]
basement
you didn't like that
i [ __ ] knew you're going to win dude
for telling you why you do the whole
straight you're like i know i would end
up winning
for a little bit
it's all about the salt
the party are the most valuable
yeah
they gave you the most points
thanks for having us nice to meet you
yeah nice meeting you dude for sure i'll
see you around yeah right yeah
hell yeah good night's
[Music]
is
we can lower you on to it
it's got a bidet
sick
yeah we should have worn it i should
wear it because i won
it is a beautiful crown
this was much chiller vibes than doing
it over there
this is more comfortable
yeah it's more laid back
i'm glad we haven't set up that now like
this now we can do it
more yeah
i don't think you really like it i'm
just i've never done it before so i'm
trying to be like a fly on the wall and
observe it and of course you know we got
a lot of voices going around so you have
a lot to take in you know i'm just
i'm kind of like okay plus like
oh we're recording this
okay you should oh
i was gonna say you should stop but i
guess it's fine
podcasts relax
so the podcast is still continuing all
right but even when everyone's gone i
get it okay
well i thought it was a fun game it
definitely takes a bright mind
nice meeting you
thanks for having me by the way yeah
i'm sure you're fine i wash my hands
because i'm sure you're fun
nice meeting you too dude let me know
when the next one is i'm so down yeah
to settle let's uh start another group
chat because i'm only allowed uh
32.
do you guys always consistently have
this many people i'd be down to even do
like three or four and we could bang on
multiple games
yeah yeah the more the merrier but this
is oh no i agree too
you could have brought your friend i
guess
yeah it's all good yeah we and he's also
like kind of a rookie too so
yeah just shows though how much you
could like control people are uneducated
i mean just like that well it changes
the whole dynamic too so imagine if
you're actually involved like trading
and being a part of it
it yeah it [ __ ] it's
it's so corny but like anything can
happen in the game though so
you know the game of life
precisely holy [ __ ] what time is it uh
yeah what's that group chat on insta or
whatever yeah sweet man who else would
want to join
when do you plan on playing any rhyme or
reason or just
whenever
uh yeah i need time randomly all right
yeah
let me figure it out
yeah yeah i'll see you around at some
bikes too yeah are you living here now
uh yeah i moved here i lived here for
four or five weeks now
so i've just been trying to get on any
sort of mic i can
i gotta come by check out kell tony
didn't see on there yeah it'd be fun
the new york people respect kill tony
i think so
yeah that's good i mean there's been a
couple people from the usa that are
beyond those guests like dave smith yeah
yeah yeah yeah
big j okay yeah oh yeah yeah he's a
regular at the seller when i was in the
loop down there all right well it's nice
to meet you man keep it good
take care i appreciate the hospitality
yeah thank you
no it was fun i can see how it gets
intense it's like